poco después de conocerse que joe biden
había sido el ganador de las elecciones
en eeuu tuiteó el líder supremo de la
revolución ali jamenéi en su cuenta en
inglés y recuperado un discurso que ha
venido haciendo en las últimas semanas y
es decir que la cultura norteamericana
más allá de quien fuera el ganador
estaba en declive tanto en la parte
política como moral y lo que había
pasado en estas elecciones era todo un
espectáculo en cuanto a otras
autoridades de la república islámica
también ha repetido lo que ha dicho el
líder y dicen que si bien quien sea el
ganador puede marcar de cierta manera la
aproximación a diferentes eventos y
puede haber una diferente manera de
hacer las cosas
esa gran política estadounidense de
acoso especialmente hacia irán no va a
cambiar pero si hay una realidad y eso
se nota en cierta manera del discurso
del gobierno que la victoria de joe by
del crea una esperanza de que vuelvan a
la mesa de negociación en el acuerdo
nuclear aunque él ha puesto como
condición que irán vuelva a cumplir esos
compromisos que ha venido retro
siendo irán ha puesto como condición de
que eeuu tendrá que pagar por lo que ha
perdido durante estos años lo que creará
un rifirrafe unas grandes conversaciones
pero se crea una esperanza aunque que
dicen que todavía falta mucho para
llegar a ese punto